TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WERE
WAITING FOR A QUORUM AND WE
WILL HEAR CENTER OWNS BILL. AND
WAITING. WE WANT TO HAVE A
COUPLE A COUPLE OF RAIN. IT'S
JUST A COUPLE RAIN. IT'S ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL WE WILL. BEGIN
THE MEETING AND OPERATE AS A
SUB COMMITTEE UNTIL WE REACH A
QUORUM THERE WILL VOTE ON TWO
THINGS- WE WILL VOTE ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO CENTER ALAN'S BILL
IS SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN. AND
THEN WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR I WILL VOTE ON
THOSE SO. AT THIS POINT. WE'D
LIKE TO. OUR FIRST SET AROUND
THE FLOOR AND HE CAN PRESENT
HIS BILL AT THIS TIME CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
TECHNICAL MOMENT IT'S OUTLINED
IN COMMENT SIX OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. OF THIS BILL SB
SEVENTY SEVEN IS AN ATTEMPT TO
MAKE MODEST REFORMS TO THE
STATE HIGHWAY RELINQUISHMENT
PROCESS IN THE HOPES OF MAKING
IT EASIER FOR LOSS OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. WHO DESIRE TO
MANAGE TO MAKE CHANGES TO A
PORTION OF A ROAD THAT NO
LONGER SERVES. THE PURPOSE OF A
TYPICAL STATE HIGHWAY HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AS LONG AS THERE'S-
A STRONG PROCESS IT'S FOLLOWED
AND- AND YOU KNOW THE STATE. I
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO THE
BILL PROPOSES AN ALTERNATIVE
PROCESS THAT WOULD PERMIT. THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO RELINQUISH
PORTIONS OF THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM TO EXCEED YOUR COUNTY-
WITHOUT EXPLICIT. LEGISLATIVE
ACTION- NOW MY INTENTION IS NOT
TO FACILITATE ANY ABDICATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHWAY SYSTEM TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. HI AND SHOULD
THE BILL MOVE FOR TODAY I'M
VERY COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUING- YEAH
SOME OF THE FOLKS AT TEN
REPRESENTS- WHO WANT GREATER
PARAMETERS AROUND THE SCOPE OF
SECTIONS OF HIGHWAYS THAT COULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A LINK WHICH
MEANT WITHOUT- EXPLICIT
LEGISLATIVE CONSENT. AND ALSO I
WANT TO MENTION THAT IT CENTER
RUBIO'S. REQUEST I WILL
SPECIFICALLY AMEND THE BILL. TO
RESTRICT ANY PORTION OF THE
SEVEN TEN. SOUTHERN STUB THAT-
THAT TERMINATES IN HER DISTRICT
FROM BEING RELINQUISH WITHOUT
THE LISTENERS APPROVAL BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTROVERSIES
BETWEEN THE VERY CITIES AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
THE REGIONAL CONCERNS ARE BEING
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT THERE- SO
FOR. BUT BUT I WILL SAY THAT
THE IDEA HERE IS THAT FOR THOSE
APPROPRIATE INSTANCES. WHERE
IT'S NOT PRACTICABLE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK THROUGH OUR
STATE BUREAUCRACY TO MANAGER
MAKE IMPORTANT CHANGES TO LOCAL
ROADS- THIS BILL WILL MAKE A
MODEST BUT IN. REPORT
IMPROVEMENTS CURRENT LAW
CREATED A TRANSPARENT SYSTEM-
THAT- THAT THERE WILL BE LESS
BUREAUCRATIC THAN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. AND ALLOW FOR THERE TO
BE SOME MORE COHERENCE AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE.
THE USER OF THIS ORDER REFER.
THANK. THANK FAVOR OF.
TEMPERAMENT INTERNATIONAL
OPERATING JUNIORS WE THAT YOU
KNOW WE REPRESENT THE CALTRANS
MAINTENANCE WORKERS WHO DO
MAINTENANCE ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM. THEN CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES ON RELINQUISHMENT
AT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED-
THAT THAT APPROVAL PROCESS
GIVES US SOME INPUT IN THE
RELINQUISHMENT PROCESS. THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN RELINQUISHMENT-
HER TERM MEMBERS IN THEIR TIME
SO IT DOES NOT- BUT THIS BILL
IN FORTY TAKES THAT IN PUT AWAY
FROM US. SO I'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS AUTHORS OFFICER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND STAFF
OF A COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH
US. TO CONTINUE TO CRAFT WAY TO
GIVE US SOME INPUT ON
RELINQUISHMENT PROCESS IF THE
LEGISLATURE'S. NOT CAN OFFER
OVERSIGHT WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
PLACE SOMEWHERE TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT AND ADDRESS CONCERNS
IF WE HAVE THEM. AND I AND I WE
DO AGREE TO OFFER THE NOTION
THAT ELECTION PROCESS SHOULD BE
STREAMLINED- AND THERE SHOULD
BE SOME. RATIONALE TO IT AS
OPPOSED TO A HAPHAZARD APPROVAL
PROCESS- BUT WE ARE LOOKING TO
FOR SOME WAY TO GIVE INPUT IF
WE NEED TO FOR MEMBERS ARE
DISPLACED FROM THAT WORK. AND
MAYBE HAVE SOME NEGOTIATIONS
WITH CALTRANS ON THAT ANY I
THINK THE AUTHOR HAS. COMMITTED.
AT LEAST HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH US MOVING FORWARD ON THAT.
AND I THINK THE WAY WHERE WE
HAD TO INTRODUCE A BILL TACK
TRUE RELINQUISH THE STATE
HIGHWAY. GOT TO BE A
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATION I THINK
IT'S CUMBERSOME- WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND I WILL ASK FOR ROLL
CALL PLEASE IN ABOUT. BATES
DOLLY DOT. DOT PRESENT OUT
JOHNNY GALGIANI PRESENT MCGUIRE
AROUND HERE PEARL PRESENT ROTH
RUBIO RUBIO PRESENCE SKINNER
NUMBER YEAH NUMBER PRESENT-
CASKEY HERE BECAUSE HE PRESENTS
OKAY THANK YOU TO HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ANYBODY LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
THE BILL OKAY THANK YOU-
OPPONENTS ANYBODY OPPOSE THE
BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
APPROVAL WITH THE- WE HAVE A
MOTION. SIR SIR RUBIO. I JUST
WANT TO TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN I KNOW
THAT- I KNOW WHAT THE INTENT IS
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT THINGS GET DONE AND
THEY DON'T GET STUCK UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT- FOR YOU I THINK
ABOUT THE AYE TO. TAKE IN THE
SEVEN TEN INTO CONSIDERATION
THAT'S BEEN AN ONGOING BATTLE
FOR DECADES AND JACK THAT WOULD
DISMANTLE LOTOF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN JOINED SEVERAL THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO. OF WE
ARE MOTION ON THIS BILL. WITH
YOU MEMBERS AS ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR. THERE'S A MOTION WE
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER ABOUT BY
WELL I BATES. DOLLY DOT. DODD
AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE AROUND. WELL I ROTH
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER AMBER
HI AMBER I WOULD HOUSING HI I.
THE MEMBERS HAVE SEVERAL SO
FAVOR LEAVE THE ROLE OF ROUTES
MEMBERS SHARED ONE MORE ITEM IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FUTURE I
WOULD BE HONORED IF YOU ALLOW
ME TO MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
CONSENT KELLER S. B. TWO SEVEN.
EIGHT. THE C. OR. SIXTY SEVEN
AND TENNESSEE ARE SIXTY SEVEN
SCR SIXTY EIGHT.THERE'S A
MOTION ON CONSENT COUNTER- CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF
VIOLATED ONE THREE AND FOUR.
CENTER ABOUT HI WELL I BATES
DOLLING. DOT DOT AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE. AROUND.
WELL I ROTH RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER. NUMBER HI I'M BURKE I
WOULD CASTING CASSIE I. THE
SERVER VOTES IN FAVOR WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THE MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT- THAT IS ALL THE
BUSINESS HERE AND ALL LEADER
ROLE OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES SO.
FOR MEMBERS THAT ARE TRAILING
IN AT THIS TIME WILL EVOKE FOR
TEN MINUTES AND THEN THE
MEETING WILL BE A JERK. THANK
YOU
. WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
DOLLINGER. SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
FIFTY SERVICE GROWN. THE
RELINQUISH I'M A. DOLLY AYE
MCGUIRE SKINNER HI CAN I. NINE
ZERO THEY HAVE NINE LOS THERE
REALLY ARE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS
ONE THREE AND FOUR CHAIR VOTING
HI SENATOR DOLLINGER. DOLLY AYE
MCGUIRE. IT SKINNER. IT'S THERE
WE HAVE ABLE TO FAVOR LEADER
BROWN CENTER THANK YOU. SO WE
JUST WENT
. HEY ARE WILL CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. SEVEN FOR.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATE MCGUIRE
WIRE I. YEAH ABOUT THAT ESTAMOS
AND IN FAVOR OF. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEMS ONE THREE AND FOUR CHAIR
VOTING I SENATE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
HI. NINETY SEVEN I ROSA FAVOR
THE OF. BY ROSE IN FAVOR WE
WILL NOW ADJOURN THE MEETING